so Carl you've been at Google for a
while now and it sounds like wow six
years and it sounds like prototyping has
changed over that time can you just sort
of talk a little bit about how that's
happened yeah you know prototyping has
evolved quite a bit in my tenure at
Google when I first came to search for
instance almost three years ago we were
focused heavily on creating web products
specifically for their desktop users
Google's shift has grown significantly
over the last few years and we've gone
mobile first and so as a result I've had
to evolve with the times and have also
shifted my development practices towards
doing full-time Android development hmm
so you now sort of lead a team of
Android developers that's right so I
lead a team of four people specifically
looking at search map and identity
products across Google awesome and I
know you've worked on some things in
there earlier stages you know that's one
of the joys of prototype because you get
to see these things before they happen
and some of them never do happen but if
you tell me a little about working on
material design sure material design was
a fantastic project to work on we spent
about a year ramping up on that before
we ever released anything to the public
I think in its infancy we were thinking
about it we called it quantum paper and
we were really thinking about this idea
that it was digital paper and so we were
thinking about how does digital paper do
things like respond to touch how do we
show layers for instance inside of that
digital paper landscape we made a number
of prototypes across the early stages
that project we even did some really
ugly ones with like some really bad
electronic mesh like touch
responsiveness stuff that ultimately we
did away with a lot of that stuff in
favor of a really simple UI and so
that's where we ended up going with the
touch ripples for instance in android i
think a much better experience for our
users it's a little simpler a little bit
cleaner and i think is a result a bit
more delightful than some of the early
mesh tron like stuff we were doing right
that makes sense and so some of these
decisions you made to sort of scrap the
this
version of a product and come out with
this simpler one was that made based on
user feedback was that made based on
some other kind of feedback was that
made sure to bat in the blue not really
out of the blue we got tons and tons of
feedback so we as a group of designers
and developers were sequestered for a
couple of months working on the project
we got lots and lots of feedback from
not only the executive sponsors of the
project but then a number of design
stakeholders as well as a lot of users
that we did tests with we did some
guerrilla like cafe style testing across
the Google campus we even brought in
outside trusted testers to give us their
feedback on the experience so you
mentioned that native prototyping is
sort of come to the forefront at Google
that's right can you talk a little bit
about why that is and sort of what you
get out of that that you wouldn't be
able to get out of just a web prototype
that you've put on a phone sure one of
the areas that I think we have focused a
great deal of energy is actually in
prototyping voice experiences this is an
area that we can't do a whole lot as far
as the website of things for instance
we're limited by some platform vendors
in the access that we have to their
api's so going with a fully native
experience means that we get a much
wider set of tools that we can work with
so for instance in the android sdk we
get much tighter integration with voice
components we can do a really beautiful
voice experience lots of delightful
animation around that experience as we
bring that prototype of that application
to life perfect thank you